so thank you to the organizers for
inviting me yet so I'm a computer
scientist interested in the theory of
evidence and this talk is going to be
about subfield in computer science which
could be called running time analysis or
complexity and analysis of so-called
randomized search heuristics this is
just an umbrella term randomized
searcher istics could be evolutionary
algorithms but also other methods
christos papadimitriou you mentioned
some of them yesterday locust very
simulated annealing and colony
optimization particle swarm optimization
they work with a set of solutions to
some problem and then they typically
would run in the rounds by initializing
and then selecting good solutions
according to some fitness and then
burying them that could be mutation or
crossover and then they select again and
goes on like this and the purpose is
here optimization so classical
optimization you have some objective
function f which maps solutions to some
value so the search space could be
anything you would like to optimize so
you would like to find a shortest part
in a graph then the search space would
visit the set of all paths so this is
the setting minimize or generally
optimize some function and such methods
would be applied in practice if you
don't have a specific problem specific
algorithm so what is done in this area
is trying to understand these methods
using tools from computer science and
then one would be interested in as you
would analyze and a randomized every
woman you would be interested in
studying the expected optimization time
its randomized things so most of the
time you would be interested in the
expectation of the running time so that
means there the time until this
algorithm has found an optimum and this
was actually already done 25 years ago
when people looked into simulated
annealing and try to derive the time
complexity of simulated and leading for
finding maximum etchings in the graph so
in from roughly 2000 done this dispute
got momentum and people who are using
and studying other kinds in particular
evolutionary algorithms from this
perspective
using the techniques are adapting the
techniques from classical randomized
algorithms and today we have quite a lot
of interesting results which tell us on
which problems evolutionary algorithms
and other search listings are patient on
which not this is particularly towards
particular for combinatorial
optimization where these turds bias here
is a discrete one there's still one
major challenge in in this area or the
analysis in this area's is facing one
major challenge maybe that even very
simple-looking settings very innocently
looking settings can be surprisingly
hard to analyze so in one intuitive
reason for this is since while these
methods they were not designed with
analysis in mind when people came up
with evolutionary algorithms in the
1960s they were interested in mimicking
evolution survival of the fittest and
they did not have a running time
analysis in like this is different when
you are as a computer scientist
designing an algorithm then you would be
when designing this I windows will be
interested in making this everything
amenable to a running time analysis so
this causes a lot of problems and for
today I would like to show you some of
the results that can be obtained in this
area also techniques and maybe discuss
what what can be achieved here
afterwards so yes my talk is divided
into three parts I will introduce to you
one important technique for the analysis
of randomized search heuristics namely
drift analysis i will show you one
application to a problem benchmark
problem so to speak which could be
called weighted hill climbing how good
are EAS at optimizing linear functions
can we get any running time balance here
and in a third part I am going to
discuss whether this drift analysis
technique could be useful for other
problems from classical computer science
so nothing about randomized search
heuristics very long but a classical
computer science problem
so let me start by explaining what
proved analysis is about so first of all
when you take an evolutionary algorithm
we say it's a randomized algorithm test
some input it has some output it will
stop after a while when we have a
stopping criterion so in principle we
should be able to define something that
is called running time and that would be
the time until this algorithm has found
an optimum to the problem assuming a
discreet problem or where or when the
problem is very hard NP hard problem
then we might be interested in arriving
at a good approximation of the optimum
evolutionary algorithms they are not
analysis friendly so they induce very
complex stochastic processes Markov
chains who's who's 20 transition
matrices are not tractable in a sense
with the exact analysis and in addition
we would like to understand something
about this come about this process that
is related to a global property we would
be interested in something that is
called first hitting time of the optimum
something that runs over many steps and
we can very rarely it's possible to to
write down this first hitting time by
expectation exactly this is really
possible however what we can often
understand roughly is what happens when
ya from one step to the next one when we
at some state in this is evolutionary
algorithm how much progress do we make
in one step this is often possible to to
get some understanding of this local
progress from one step to the next one
and driftin a decision natural is is the
magic tool that allows us to translate
statements on the one-step progress on
this local behavior into a global
statement on the running time the first
hitting time of the optimum please
interrupt me there are any questions I'm
going to show you a simple scenario
which is called local in words so I
really local means we've tried we find
out something about what happens from
one step to the next one solo
scale with those but can the steps be
big in some sense through the steps are
small and never come so this a time step
would be around a generation in and
definition of everything so we could
understand what happens from one
generation to the next one I understand
that one thing I to do from one
generation to the next is just
completely scramble or DNA random yes
iris a sense in which gave local in some
you don't know yeah yeah local actually
in a local step on the time scale of a
very drastic change put happy that's
right so local only refers to clear the
time scale so there's an average ative
group is about that um you would like to
analyze how long it takes until your
process reaches some optimal males in
many cases you can come up with a
distance from the optimum these are than
random variables discrete random
variables in this case so this XT are
distances from the optimum for example
in a bit string problem it could this
distance could show you or give you how
many bits are wrong pepper with respect
to the global optimum so let's say you
are able to derive some bounds on the
local progress from one step to the next
one this is called drift if you have a
lower bound on the script an expectation
then I claim gluttonous as a nervous you
to button get a bound on the expected
time to reach the optimum this is this T
0 this the time the random time it takes
until the process we just loved an
optimum we are interested in the
expected value so here's an example
let's say we are at distance 10 with
probability a half ago 29 with
probability a half we go to seven so the
expected change would be too is that
second point
realistic good thing that you might have
on certain simplifies property this can
happen if you have a local change tell
me of course this is just an example
history a map that you have small
changes this is what we've royalty the
second way and for all steps where we
haven't reached the optimum yet so this
is the condition that it's in here in
this expectation so some very long
season upload d represent the discrete
time d represents the progress from one
stage it's a discrete I'm process
exactly up but for what path we have if
it's with respect to some distance
measure so we we look into the search
space and they simplify things but by
putting up the distance measure on the
search space so question to you so what
do you think what is your guess you
start a distance em in every step you
reduce an expectation ID how long does
it take in expectation to reach the
optimum
and over d yeah exactly so when this is
a somewhat surprising a surprising
result in the sense that this expected
change here the expectations of
randomness it goes from yeah it goes
then into it the expected time to reach
the optimum so if it was a deterministic
process then this would be accepted and
here it translates into the average time
and if you were to never know about so
if you know that your progress from time
T to time t plus t plus 1 is bounded
from above by D then the expected time
to reach zero is at least and overly
then you have a lower bound so this is
actually rather old result from
stochastic processes called respect to
walls inequality but it was not used in
evolutionary algorithms in this sense
before 2000 @ 1 and this is one of the
major things that you would use to
analyze such simple evolutionary
algorithms however using you mean and
trying to do mathematical and also a
mathematical analysis yeah a
mathematical analysis to write a bound
like this algorithm takes n log n steps
until it finds the optimal this was one
scenario the simplest one but one thing
that is a little bit unrealistic is that
we assume that we always make a progress
up at least eat no matter how far we
away from the optimum it was here
yesterday whenever you get closer to the
exactly so this was a warm-up example so
what we often have been practiced saw in
in the processes we consider is a
multiplicative script so still let's say
we started n a distance end but now we
have here that we reduce the distance
from one step to the next by by
something that is dependent on the
current distance this is expected
additionally expectation and um the
dependencies as follows that we would
use by an expected Delta vector
oh where we are so this means large
distance large progress small distance
small progress very natural when we are
closed and there are many things that
can go wrong when we have highway that
might be many things we could get right
to make progress so here's an example
this Delta is detected by which we would
use this data could be enough so in
expectation we would get from 10 to five
we go to get from a 24 on and from two
to one so let's look into this having
some what would you guess if you have
distance em in the beginning and half
the distance in every step of
expectation how long does it take to
reach to reach the optimum yes is a
discrete thing it's this questionnaire
is a discrete thing from one you will
jump into them 20 quite finishing for it
you will never get there by the finish
so it's a lower bound here if you if
you're happy with the ending sorry 11
then log it may affect it so and rested
you're right Adam and abstract it away
from from this gap we had to help you
between 1 and 0 so it's a discrete thing
where we when we are at one then we
would have to jump in 20 in a non
increasing process and that's correct up
to after terms we have a result that is
called the multiplicative drift theorem
that would give us that the time to
reach the optimum is best be twice the
natural logarithm and in general the
multiplicative 50 room is like this
tells us that the time to reach the
optimum is the logarithm of the initial
distance plus 1 divided by this factor
which will reduce the arm is this also a
lower bound in general
so this means when you know that your
multiplicative progress is at most Delta
s so do things turn around as we have
before
no it exactly they don't turn around
because it could happen that we have an
extreme case that let's say we have a
process that from the current state with
probability half doesn't do anything but
with probability up jumps into the
optimum then an expectation we would
have the distance so this means in order
to have a lower part in the
multiplicative drift we have to assume
more on the process so then we have to
assume that this process it only makes
small steps because in this scenario
here with the having with probability I
have into the optimum probability I have
to don't do anything we just had to wait
for this super step and the expected
time to which the optimum would be only
too but in evolutionary algorithms we
often have such a concentration and then
we also get another bundle this time so
this is an error that is called
multiplicative group and that is much
more typical than additive drift in the
analysis of evolutionary algorithms
because of this fact that your progress
is proportional to how far you are away
from the optimal though this was brought
into the theory of the A's by during
enhanced binson and Goldberg and nuts I
have not too long ago in 2010 but these
are the tools and in the natural again
it was about try to bound the progress
from one set to the next and this will
be translated into a bound on the time
to reach the optimum
well show you one warm-up example and
how we can actually derive actual
running time pounds using this
multiplicative theorem the algorithm is
extremely simplified it's a 1 plus 1 EA
which that starts off with a uniform
solution is raised up its strings and
you have to minimize such a function
back in there a big bit string to a
number I just called F a pseudo boolean
function only one individual and
mutation selection goes as follows we
take the current with string X and click
each bit independently with probability
1 over N so in expectation we would slip
one bit and then if the new search point
is at least as good as the previous one
then we take the new search but the
selection and Ellis is summation
otherwise we reject it and we do look
this until some stopping criteria
witness for third a problem we consider
here to show you how multiplicative
proved actually gives us running 10
pounds is also again and extremely
simplified problem but this is how all
this business started with extremely
simplified things the problem is called
one max actually we are minimizing here
and one next problem problem a bit
string is just returns to us the number
of ones in the bisque its strength so we
have to reach the 0 0 string
so and with multiplicative ripped we can
now use these to get through this stuff
that we analyze the progress from one
step to the next and everything is only
dependent on the current number of ones
in the big screen because this outwardly
symmetrical so it doesn't look at the
decisions so our distance from the
optimum would be the number of one base
in the corrected screen which we have to
reduce to zero in order to optimize this
function and this number one which it
could be number between one and n
assuming that we still have a one bit at
some place we can get rid of this one
bit if this algorithm flips this one
between 20 and does not fit the rest and
the probability for this it can be
bounded quite quite well it's one so it
is exactly for a single one bit 1 over n
times 1 minus 1 over N to the power n
minus 1 the first thing is flipped a bit
and the second term is do not flip the
rest and this is one from below by 1
over Y n where is on this number third
if you have s of these 1 bits left then
you can apply the reality of expectation
and you get this type of result that if
your parent distance is s then you would
use your distance by something that is
your current distance times some vector
s over en the factor is 1 over N so in
the example before this Gator was a half
but here it's much smaller and then we
can track this inheritance again the
multiplicative great theorem the
expected time to reach the optimum is
the logarithm of the starting value plus
1 divided by Delta and plugging this in
we get a bound which is e + ln m that's
a lower auditor in the order n log n so
running times as you would see in them
in classical algorithms will be running
time we have for sorting I ever written
for example this the kind of result we
would like to obtain
twistys so again this was a
oversimplified settings but in fact you
can use to fill analysis to analyze more
complex he aids population HD edge like
this one without going into the details
the simple GA where we have the
population and we do not only have
mutation but also crossover we can e
analyze the A's on more interesting
problems than one max on combinatorial
optimization problems as you would
consider them in computer science
minimum spanning trees maximum etchings
and also harder problems NP hard
problems like makes them scheduling and
more recently drift analysis is a major
yeah a major tool to analyze the case in
noisy optimization since noise it will
make everything that was deterministic
before in some sense domestic soil
analysis selection will no longer be
elitist in some sense and then all
methods that were used before for
deterministic selection mechanism they
do not work any longer but rift analysis
still works um yes
this brings me to the second part so I
showed you the one next before and now a
more advanced example worked analysis
where I considered something that could
be called generalized one mex linear
functions and this is again an extremely
innocently looking problem but it's
surprisingly hearts to come up with a
good running 10 pounds and while doing
this we get some consequences of the
theorems and these consequences can be
summarized as follows we get that in
this setting a mutation probability
recommended in practice 1 over N is
optimal in theory for the whole class of
linear function then we can also prove
that is basically on linear functions
it's best to take this over simplified 1
plus 1 EA it doesn't pay off to use a
population it doesn't pay up to use a
different mutation probability doesn't
pay off to use stochastic selection so
the setting is generalized 1x as I
promised a linear Sulu boolean function
so the function value is now awaited
some of the one bits and the weights are
positive numbers without loss of
generality and we also can assume that
the bit of highest index has the largest
weight then these weights might not be
very different in the world makes case
all of them are one and the first again
is how long does it take an evolutionary
algorithm to find the optimum minimizing
this so how long does it take the
algorithm to find the or zero string we
can consider in addition to 1 plus 1 EA
on another even simpler renovatio istic
called rent buys local search where the
mutation is different mutation selects
exactly one bit and flips it uniformly
at random so if this can get stuck in a
local optimum um the one plus one inning
for comparison it would
with each bit a dependable poverty one
over N or more generally with
probability P so we can fit many bits in
a step we can't get stuck in local
Optima so to find out the running time
pound remember with one next we have
this n log N one might be tempted to
think that we can just reuse this one
next result from before so that the
words are not so important or if you
don't know the multiplicative raped you
have no computer science quite well and
that this is of randomized I wasn't
venomous could think that this is the
coupon collector for them coupon
collector problem means that you have a
set of things and objects you would like
to collect in each round you get
independently one object and you wait
until you have all of them with
replacement it objects might arrive
again and again and what we have to
collect here is zero bits so to speak
though they are interesting part is dead
with a randomized local search which
flips only a single bit in a step we can
apply these classical methods so a
randomized local search it could do two
things it could flip one bit 20 which
leads to a better function value the
lower function value will be accepted it
could try to flip a zero bit to one
which leads to a higher function value
this will be rejected so it will never
lose zero bits it has an accountant
screen then the analysis is like on one
mix for this randomized local search but
this is not a case for I'm the general
problem so the 1 plus 1 EA it might do
arm nasty things by flipping many bits
in a step
um for example if we have a third point
like this the first n minus 1 bits all
of them are 0 and the most significant
bit is one and let's say that the way
that this most significant bit outweighs
all the other bits together then it
could in principle happen that we accept
the step that flips orbits in a step
resets the most significant bit from 120
and flips all the other less significant
bits from due to one we have set this
thing because the function value
decreases however we have lost almost
all 0 which we have before and this
introduces a major complication to the
running time analysis and people this is
actually a long list long list of words
from different people they have tried to
come up with increasingly improved
running 10 pounds for the 1 plus 1 EA on
an arbitrary linear function with the
standard mutation probability so without
drift analysis you might be able to come
up with a bond that is Big O of n square
but the first proof that we actually
have the same type of running time n log
n as with one next this was yep only
available in 98 and German version in
2003 too and this was some proof of
cited pages extremely complicated and
people have been trying this before so
this was kind of breakthrough when this
n log n bar was food for an arbitrary
linear function and then people look
into this more closely for one mex we
had e + ln n to lower order terms so
people were wondering can these steps
flipping benefits actually increase the
running time compared to the bonded
clips so in the first answer given by a
gas people in 2008 was they can in
principle they might increase the
running time but if they do then at most
by a factor of two and then this gap was
narrowed to 39
and we also have a little fun so within
the class of linear functions the
running time it can vary by at most
thirty-nine percent maybe one is the
easiest bling of linear functions on
other functions it might take a bit a
little bit longer this was an open
problem but in fact the answer is this
is not the case so on all linear
functions who basically have the same
running 10 pound so this is written down
here in a bit more general flavor so the
running time bound is up to lower order
terms is this guy here it's e to the C
divided by C times m ln n commutation
probability c / n so if c equals 1 we
have the e + ln n bound which we had for
one mex we have it for all in their
functions yes and as I said this also
depends on the mutation probability so
we could experiment with different
mutation problems it's 2 over N or a
half Oakland but it turns out that this
guy here is minimized for c plus 1 so on
every linear function it's best to use
the standard mutation probability and
this is a theoretical answer so to speak
to on the recommendation in genetic
algorithms to use one over the bitstream
length as mutation probability so I'm
probably I don't have time to give you
all details of the proof but I can give
you some some iteration and some
interesting insights we get from this
one inside is that this e to the C
divided by C this is the waiting time
until we have a mutation that flips only
a single bit so this whole process
before running time bound seems to be
governed by the steps that flip only a
single bit so the steps that bit more
bits they could in principle between
detrimental but in terms of the running
time they they aren't but they do not
have either so what we have to do to
come up with with its bound is to talk
about distance functions
so within the class of linear functions
we might have to case we have we have
many cases in here let's add to pests
that are so to speak extreme the one
makes cases that the function value is
just the sum of the bits always that one
always are the same we could also have a
function called binary value is also
linear function where we have
exponentially increasing weights and
here we have this phenomenon phenomenon
that the most significant bit outlays
all less significant tips together so on
one max which so before that it's not
possible that the algorithm loses a
little bit he's written 1 plus 28
because orbits are at the same weight if
the number of of 1 bits currently is s
then this number will only decrease so
the distance melton one which is not
increasing in multiplicative for it
works and gives us this bound with
binary value we have can have the
extreme steps that make us lose on the
number of zero bits one could consider
the stochastic change of the number of
one bits from one step to the next one
this is a random variable is Delta how
do they how many want is to again from
time T to time T plus one what do we
lose and on a general linear function
this this change it can be negative
which is bad we have a positive
expectations and accepted steps but this
is too small in terms of additive of an
edited drift in order to get the
boundary would like to have if we just
look into the expected change of the one
bits then we don't get the n log n loud
so what we have to do is we have to come
up with the distance function so do not
measure the distance from the optimum in
one bits but into something that is
little bit more involved for example
with the binary value we should so
somehow favor the bits that have a large
coefficients at large coefficients in
our distance function
so if we have another fight a linear
function we would like to optimize then
the number of 1 bits as a conclusion is
usually not a good potential function
which is the same as a distance function
when people who are looking into
potential functions one potential
function could be that we take the
current value its separated sum of one
leads this boot leads us to the
multiplicative Britain would like to
have but in this multiplicative grift we
also have the logarithm of the starting
value and the function value binary
value is exponential the logarithm of
something exponential well in this case
it would be linear we do not get this n
log n so the potential function it
should be not there as extremist binary
valued if the weights of this functional
still increasing then it should a little
bit compress the weights and what was
done already by the Austrian in bed now
they came up with a potential function
that always looked like this they have
about half of the bits you've got weight
of to the lighthouse we've got a weight
of one in this way we somehow favor in
the distance function the heavy bits the
bits with a high proficient but this is
not necessarily the best idea to use as
a distance function if your function at
hand is one max if your function at hand
from this class of linear function to be
minimized this one x why shouldn't we
use one x as a distance function if it
happens to be binary value we can't work
with binary value as a distance function
because the ways are too steeply
increasing but we might use much slowly
increasing weights and this idea to
define the potential function depth it
to the actual linear function this is
called adaptive crypt analysis
introduced by a turncoat
so there are new potential functions for
this this idea looks roughly like this
without explaining the details but it
has some exponential component or the
base is much smaller than 2 and it also
has a component that allows us to obtain
one nights as a potential function if
the linear function is one next so what
goes into the potential function is the
mutation probability and also the
original weight of the linear function
and then we get this behavior that if
the function has steam coefficients then
we also have exponentially increasing
coefficients for Britain much smaller
base if we have something like 1 X then
the potential function would be one next
we refuse the original function in that
case then we get the multiplicative
drift multiplicative drift we would like
to have
and what follows from this analysis is
also that one x is the easiest linear
function so the optimization time within
the class of linear function
systematically smallest we get the lower
bounds using this concentration property
in multiplicative lift we don't have
large gems and we can also see how the
running time varies depending on the
mutation probability P it turns out that
we have something that is called a phase
transition only the mutation probability
is login / n it's still polynomial if it
is larger than its exponential a super
polynomial another thing I mentioned
before is that in fact we can identify a
1 plus 1 EA as the fastest i've written
within this class of every witness where
we can use a population of arbitrary
size and we can decide to select any
search fund from the history for
mutation head mutation probability could
be something which is bigger than 1 over
N and it turns out that the one plus one
year is the optimal able to attend this
class on linear paths good I'm finally
in the third part i would like to talk
about recent developments in ripped
analysis which comes little bit
addresses this expected value of the
running time and um as a consequence of
this recent development we might see
that rib dinner this is also useful for
other purposes outside the theory of
bread in my search heuristics so expect
a time n log n for one x is fine but in
an expected time could be misleading on
multimodal problems to have a problem
like this year from the seminal paper
the cost yells in big nough a function
called distance which is basically a
parabolic function with probability a
half you could climb up to a local
optimum you would initialize in the
middle roughly with the one plus one AAA
so then we would affect I said with
probability a half maybe to cut off the
left branch Empress probability I have
the right branch but the left branch
leads to a local optimum and from this
you have to put all bids in a step to
jump into the global optimum so we have
a very studious could be
with probability a half we have
exponential waiting time with
probability a half we have basically one
mex and we have polynomial time for
putting these two things together
linearity sorry block of total
probability tells us that the expected
running time of this case would be
exponential for the 1+1 yay but you
agree probably this function is not
difficult we could just restart this
algorithm when it gets stuck in the
local optimum or running in parallel and
every second trial of this I written
roughly will make it climb up the right
branch and find the global optimum so an
exponential running time is not
necessarily in education plans we need
more about the distribution of running
times this is also something that p is
is quite common in analysis of
algorithms and stochastic processes we
would like to talk about concentration
of measure I'm looking into for example
the number of one gets in the initial
bit string it is well known that this is
very sharply concentrated around the
expected value in expected in
expectation we have n half 1 bits but
they are tools called the channel bounds
to tell us actually that the real the
actual number of one gets in a uniform
good swing it did leads from this
expected value by no more than a square
root of the number of 1 bits so more
precisely probability that it deviates
by a vector Delta times the square root
is already exponentially small with
respect to this Delta so this is a lower
order term the square root can we do
something can you have temp something
like this for our River socialistic
evolutionary algorithms and in fact
there is one such a result and it was
already in from the multiplicative griff
analysis paper it shows that we also
have a so-called upper tail on for the 1
plus 1 EA the probability that the 1000
a on one max needs more than the
expected value significantly more and
the significantly more
a negative term of delta m is
exponentially small with respect to
Delta so we in this case not this is
actually the multiplicative griff
theorem by don't Goldberg it has these
tables built in so you use the
multiplicative drift I showed you in the
beginning but the actual field limit
does not only talk about the expected
value but also about the probability of
needing significantly more than the
expected value so this was one side the
upper tail and we did not have beef was
a statement on the lower tail and in
fact with proved analysis with tailbones
a recent development we can also get the
lower tips and in many cases we have a
very sharp concentration of the running
time around the expected value this
tells us that surprisingly the running
times are more or less deterministic
despite the fact that these I rhythm are
really heavy heavily using randomization
in every step at every bit this could
also be interesting from from a
practical perspective before they tell
us well we know prior quite precisely
where we are with this I wouldn't at a
certain point of time
yeah and it's the we get or I will show
you a few examples in the next time we
get a statement like this that I'm
deviation by a by a delta factor of
something that is less than the expected
time so in a delta factor times a lower
order term of the expected time compared
to the expectant this is exponentially
unlikely and what we have to use here to
get these hairy bounds in general is
something that is called worked in a
separate trial bonds a reasoned work
with Paris dear Laila where we first
liquid look into the one-step drift we
have a canonical potential function
inbounder what is called moment
generating function of this potential
passion and maybe it's possible maybe
it's not but if we succeed in bounding
this moment generating function by
something less than 1 then we have a
table but one has to do the maths with
the moment generating function and one
gets a very analogous thing for a lower
tail look into the one-step bridge and
the expected value potential function
moment generating function this is the
recipe so to speak and this users for
this one plus one AAA on one begs coming
back to your question that film well the
expected time it was basically e + ln m
and a deviation of more than delta x n
around this expectation put above or
below this expectation it's
exponentially smaller and the same thing
goes for all linear functions and for
other benchmark functions we have
similar statements for of course some
simple functions which are you d model
there we have for example that the
expected running time is n square but a
deviation of delta x n square root of n
is already exponentially and lightly
with respect to this Delta
so finally something quite different we
can be w showed where the expectation
was anything but the Prime once again
you have likely to get back to that you
have results on all so far and they're
actually we don't have a sharp
concentration so they level they are
have proved that with probability a half
we have a financial challenges Sofia we
have a very few distribution this is um
yeah some sense of badges distribution
because it's very skewed and this a half
of the mass on an exponential running
time half of the probability mass on a
polynomial running time whether
presumably more complicated versions of
them where if your number of times
you're running a parallel at large yeah
then the expected time but we've
dominated by the short kid or exactly
then my other was the most the more
padula become complicated ones like that
which have exactly an interesting a
teacher a very good point that would be
an interesting and extension of this
crypt analysis with Taylor bands to
parallel runs off of one plus twenty
years or more complex things so great
for a good point I think this is
possible mmm but i mentioned i would
like to talk about something that is not
directly connected to evolutionary
algorithms um something that is very
common in computer science analysis of
randomized algorithms recurrence
relations analysis of recursive
algorithms recurrence relation is that
the running time they say this T of n is
a running time can be written as M some
some a certain effort for simplicity is
one here plus the running time on a
smaller problem this age of em is a the
size of a derived problem the I wouldn't
of course itself recursively and we have
this increase of for example but here's
it's a very simple recurrence relation
but the major thing is that this age of
n the size of the derived problem it's
random a random number between one and n
and suppose we know the expected
of the derived problem and of course we
also have to have a stopping criterion
if the problem is 0 then we do not have
to spend any work at all so this is a
scenario that was considered by my cup
so what he did he'd arrived very clever
tailbones the tailbones in this
particular example they would relate to
an expected 2022 a deviation above
something that is the solution of the
deer animals with talents so he talks
about what is the probability that the
running time is a delta term bigger than
something that's called U of M view of
em would be the running time of the
process in which you instead of using a
random problem size the derived public
views well the expected size which you
know has the actual size with
probability 1 and because this is this
scenario knows much more complicated
scenarios and get stale bonds but of
course what we get here is a stochastic
process again we start off with problem
size m and when we go from time T to
time T plus 1 the problem size will be
at the next step the size of the derived
problem this age function that we have
here the recurrence this age function it
could be anything it could spur examine
expectation of the problem and we are in
the scenario of good analysis although
this world is near the girls came up
um think i think so i think it's but in
the capital he considers many different
different applications for example of a
quick sort where they also have this
fault Mystikal currents so i'm not sure
what was the first application of this
kind the very natural thing is
randomized quicksort but this doesn't
fit destruction um one application from
the car papers he uses his tail bones in
order to analyze the random
combinatorial structure so I guess all
of you know what a permutation is a
random uniform permutation of n elements
something that is by the way used in
quicksort randomized quicksort um people
are interested in structures of french
permutations in one structure is cycles
and permutations the cycle is just a
sequence of NEC subset well one index
maps to the next one in this sequence
and it wraps around it is well known
that each permutation can be written as
a concatenation of cycles and it can be
useful to count cycles in the analysis
of bring my algorithms the number of
cycles is a random variable there could
be one big cycle of all elements there
would be many small cycles of holy
single element help thumb notice that
the number of titles it can also be
written in a recursive fashion the
number of cycles in a permutation of n
elements is one plus the number of
cycles in the permutation of H of n
elements by H of n is uniform between 0
and n minus 1
and then he gets a Taliban from his
technique the Taliban says that the
probability that the actual number of
cycles is significantly more than the
binary logarithm of n is exponentially
small in this binary logarithm comes
from the solution of this deterministic
d randomized to accounts because here we
have that the size of the derived
problem is between 0 and n minus 1 so an
expectation we cut off half of the
elements so it's having having having
having what this gives rise to new to a
line reloaded interestingly this is not
the expected number of cycles in a
random permutation so in combinatorics
is well known that the expected number
is the natural logarithm well the binary
logarithm is bigger than the natural log
so in this sense the statement tells us
about something in terms of a deviation
above something that is not the expected
value and then we have the sharp
concentrated over there the tale without
a exponential increase decreasing tail
and this in some sense it's necessary
because the only thing that is used in
caps technique is this expected size of
the drive problem and then this
technique is optimal in loop Elizabeth
table to follow a different approach
there we can use the distribution of the
stochastic process as we go from time T
2 10 PT plus 1 in the drift analysis
with tail bones then we get a sharp
concentration around the real expected
value very similar to share thoughts but
again calf technique is optimal assuming
that you only know the expected size the
derived problem you have to very much
more effort in order to exploit the
distribution
obviously this was just a
proof-of-concept how drift nalysis could
work in the analysis of brendan brendan
recursions a very simple case and
carpenters much more complicated cases
for example that this effort spending
the apparent that is not a constant or
that you have world more than one
recursive call as a result and we do not
know what what you again get any case
yeah the concludes the third part on
delta my my talk so it was advertised
ngui analysis as one major technique for
the analysis of Brenda's virtue ethics
in particular evolutionary algorithms
and then considered one example
surprisingly difficult to handle namely
1 plus 1 EA on linear functions
thriftiness this gives us tight bounds a
pillow other terms and these bounds they
tell us that the whole process is
written by the steps flipping single
bits and the other steps flipping many
bits they do not help but they do not
harm either for linear functions we
could prove as a result from this that
the practical news mutation probability
1 over N is optimal in theory on this
problem and that this one plus 1 EA this
greedy 1 plus 1 EA is the best thing to
do on this linear function problem when
you restrict yourself to a Britain's
using population and mutation
installation not talking about crossover
and the yard into it analysis can be to
come up with a good potential action
finally the third part was about drift
analysis with tail bones and rip the
nurses can give us tail bones and a one
thing that can be learned here my
hypothesis is we have looked into
evolution inspired algorithms from with
computer science from a computer science
perspective this may be a promising
thing because at least we have some idea
that the techniques developed here they
might also be useful for problems from
classical theoretical
just friends yep so this concludes my
talk and thank you for your attention